well we begin in gaza where in the last
few years dozens of palestinian families
have rushed to evacuate their tower
block
under the threats of israeli airstrikes
the al-andalus tower complex just north
of gaza city
has been targeted it's the sight of as
many as
90 homes which now sit empty after
residents gathered what they could
and fled well this was the moment one of
israel's warning shots hit
these smaller hits are used to alert
residents of much larger strikes
on the way while israel's bombardment of
the gaza strip has continued
throughout the nights and into wednesday
at least 222 palestinians have been
killed
since the military offensive began
against hamas and other
palestinian armed groups
just a short while ago factions in gaza
launched another barrage of rockets into
southern israel while most were
intercepted by the air defense system
known as the iron dome
some caused damage in the towns of
beersheba ashdod and ashkelon
twelve people in israel have been killed
since the start of the conflict
including
two children and while
tuesday was the palestinian date of rage
today
wednesday is a day of mourning funerals
have taken place
in ramallah for two of the four people
killed in the occupied west bank on
tuesday
it happened after the first palestinian
general strike in
decades ended in violence and bloodshed
more than 160 people were injured
as well as two israeli soldiers
another palestinian president mahmoud
abbas is appealing to the international
community to help
end the violence
we call for an immediate seas of
hostilities against our fellow
palestinian gaza strip
then we can engage in any dialogue which
will no doubt culminate with
ending the israeli occupation
the establishment of a palestinian state
with jerusalem as its a capital
and the fair and just agreeable
solution of the refugees including the
un resolutions in order to have a
permanent
lasting peace in the region well we have
correspondence on both sides of this
conflict in a moment
we'll go to imran khan who's standing by
for us in southern israel
first though let's get the latest from
yumna al-sayed who joins us from outside
the al-shifa hospital
in gaza yumna how has the situation been
in the last few hours and what's the
latest from where you are
it's still the 10th day of aggression
hearing god that the raids are still
going on the israeli raids are still
going on the targeting
has not stopped this morning four people
who have been killed have arrived to the
hospital
including a journalist yusuf abu hussain
who was killed in a targeting of his
home in sheikh radwan neighborhood
a number of people who have been wounded
because of the way of the raids that
haven't stopped since
the early hours of the morning and until
now have also arrived
to shifa hospital also another
journalist was
in in part of those people who have been
wounded and arrived to the hospital a
couple of hours ago
we we witness uh a lot of humanitarian
crises that are going on now
due to the amounts of people who are
displaced and evacuating their homes
because of the targeting every now and
then
and the the crisis of the corona and the
amount of people who are
are being displaced and put in
in little areas together like the unrest
schools and governmental schools
and uh the health the health crisis that
are still going on in the hospitals
due to the outages of power and lack of
water
and the not an israel not allowing any
humanitarian or medications
to aid to enter this trip in order to
help out these hospitals now in these
crisis
amnesty international also said that the
targeting of homes
for civilians in gaza amounts to war
crimes that's in
the latest statement by amnesty
international until now in the 10th day
we have witnessed more than 500
residential buildings and apartments
that have been directly targeted
okay they're live for us outside the al
shifa hospital yuma thank you very much
for that update
let's take you now to southern israel
imran khan is standing by
for us there imran we just heard the
view from inside
gaza uh but in israel they're also
facing barrages of rocket fire what more
can you tell us
well i can tell you that in the last
hour we did see a big barrage of rocket
fire coming from
gaza strip which is just behind me over
there now i have to say
the iron dome defense system that's a
rocket defense system which shoots up
smaller rockets that uh blow those
rockets as they're going
over blow them up uh did actually work
it happened kind of above
our heads actually and we saw at least
six or seven rockets explode
but some of those rockets did manage to
land in the city of ashkelon
which isn't far from where i'm standing
right now and that's of
a real concern to the aid agencies
particularly the united nations
they've got trucks parked outside of
karum abu salam
crossing into gaza that's not very far
away from where i'm standing
also the border cro the barrier crossing
it's about two kilometers
that way they've been there for 24 hours
for 24 hours they've been negotiating
with the israelis to open that barrier
crossing
and let that aid in now the israelis
shut the barrier crossing
on tuesday after allowing a couple of
trucks through after it came
under mortar attack from inside gaza
where one
israeli soldier was injured now there
has been a tit for tat
uh going on by no means anywhere
near fair or anything like that but
what the palestinian factions are saying
is that their positions were attacked
before the convoy entered near kharam
abu salam and that's why
they attacked that crossing all of this
means that this aid is simply stuck
at the border but hello you have to
remember this isn't a magic wand this
isn't
all the aid that gaza needs it's
actually just a tiny
amount and if they can't get that in it
doesn't bode well for any kind of
ceasefire
for any immediate movement the eight
agencies the united nations
is trying out is hoping that they might
be able to get it in
at some point today but the israelis
don't seem to be moving on that
okay imran khan they bring us the very
latest from southern israel
imran thank you very much in deeds